[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'université paris saclay est très très
concerné par les problématiques
étudiante actuellement avec la crise
sanitaire et depuis le premier
confinement donc nous avons mis en place
toute une série de dispositifs pour
aider les étudiants les aider à distance
les aider à revenir ensuite sur les
campus
c'est une université qui est engagée
aussi dans la lutte contre les
discriminations dans l'égalité des
chances
nous avons mis en place des différents
dispositifs d'être social avec des aides
matérielles pour les étudiants en
difficulté d aide aussi à l'achat
d'ordinateurs portables un
accompagnement pour trouver des
logements un accompagnement aussi des
dispositifs d aide alimentaire
nous sommes aussi soucieux des étudiants
en situation de handicap qui souffre
particulièrement dans cette circonstance
quoi d'isolement de confinement et kylie
qui va des compensées des situations
psychologiques graves concernant les
aides sociales donc l'université en son
sein donc une commission qui se nomme
donc asus qui est en partenariat qui se
fait en collaboration avec les
assistantes sociales du cros depuis donc
le premier confinement on a doublé le
nombre de commissions à savoir donc de
grandes commissions par mois qui traite
à peu près 80 son dossier par commission
pour des aides sociales et des aides
matérielles notamment donc l'aide à la
fin d'un ordinateur portable ou d'une
tablette l'aide à la connexion pour
faire connaître ces différents
dispositifs nous avons mis en place
plusieurs webinaire sur les aides
sociales sur le logement également sur
les violences sexistes et sexuelles car
on sait que pendant ces périodes de
confinement il ya eu une recrudescence
les problématiques de violence à la
maison et donc c'est webinaire ont été
suivis par plus d'une centaine
d'étudiants à chaque fois et nous avons
récemment remis en place ces webinaire
après des études sondage auprès des
étudiants nous avons constaté que le
besoin était plus un besoin
de reprise de confiance en soi qu'un
besoins pédagogiques et nous pensons que
donc c'était plus approprié de commencer
par remettre du lien avec les étudiants
pour qu'ils aient envie de revenir et
leur faire connaître les différents
dispositifs leur faire connaître les
campus leur faire connaître les
dispositifs dead est que dans un
deuxième temps
à ce moment là nous mettrons en place le
tutorat pédagogique
[Musique]